hello everyone and welcome to the first
game that finished from round two of
this year's Norway chess tournament
Magnus and Wesley at the classical game
ended in a draw it was uh it was a you
know an okay game the Berlin defense and
uh not a lot was happening there so of
course players uh called it a draw and
they went into Armageddon uh this is
Armageddon and it's quite a wild game
pieces will be sacrificed the king will
be hunted so let's see uh what happened
here in the Armageddon uh or the player
with the white pieces has 10 10 minutes
on the clock the player with the black
piece says seven minutes on the clock
but of course the white has to win if
it's a draw uh then black wins the
encounter so Magnus has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 sorry about that
they will have a repetition uh sort of a
repetition for a few moves of what
happened in their classical game Ponte
E5 Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and
Bishop to B5 which is kind of nice as
you also get to see what happened in the
classical game Knight to F6 was the one
for the Berlin defense D3 Bishop the C
five and now the trade captures captures
on C6 we have castles and now
uh we often say that you can play this
many different ways as the E5 Pawn is
hanging you can defend it with Queen to
E7 you can play Knights to D7 to defend
the pawn you can play Bishop to G4 or
Bishop to D6 those are the fourth uh the
four most common moves that you will see
and Wesley was for uh Bishop to D6 so
okay Magnus goes for Bishop to G5 in the
in the classical Knight the D2 was
played which is the most common move but
here Magnus plays Bishop to G5 and there
are about a few games where this move
was played it's actually a favorite
continuation of alireza firuja he played
it uh three times in top level chess uh
with uh mixed results by that I mean one
lost one draw uh and the one win uh and
the buy some other very strong player so
here we have Ponte H6 Bishop to H4 and
queen to E7 now and in the game that I
mentioned alireza did play this against
Hikaru Nakamura in the 20 20 St Louis
Blitz tournament where Knight the D2 was
played Knight B to D2 was played uh but
here we have Pawn to D4 Magnus
immediately strikes in the center and it
is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game uh which is uh you
know it's like a party considering this
is the Berlin defense
uh so Bishop to G4 uh developing uh also
painting the Knight making uh cause and
waste some time thinking about what
happens if the pawn is captured can I
beat the D2 be played uh and Magnus says
yep you can have your Pawn so here we
have Knight beta D2 but Wesley castles
first and now Rook to E1 we have Pawn to
G5 a bishop to G3 and now Knights the H5
putting pressure on the bishop here it
is a very strong piece so yeah Wesley
wants to take care of it uh mess up a
magnus's pawn structure in front of the
king and then Advance those pawns and
open up the the king so C3 and now e
captures on D4 and you have to decide do
you wanna go for some like captures and
queen to A4 or do you want to trade on
D6 first then both uh both ideas are
nice for example if Bishop captures
Queen captures You're Gonna Play Queen
to a for now put pressure on the A7 Pawn
but it doesn't matter just the captures
on C3 and you don't care about A7 you're
winning a lot of material here so you
have to recapture
uh and then Bishop captures an F3 Knight
captures and queen to C5 takes care of
the A7 problem and the black is just
better here so that's one way to do it
another one is what happened in the game
is C capture Sun D4 but it also comes
with um a a really awesome uh well at
least an exchange sacrifice but maybe
more uh Wesley plays Bishop to B4 of
course he doesn't allow the queen to
jump to A4 because then you just capture
an F3 and the Knight cannot move but
interestingly that's exactly what Magnus
plays so or rather you should play
something like a let's say Ponte A3 then
uh you you would have to decide what you
probably Bishop captures on F3 first G
captures and okay uh you will uh have
messed up your Pawn structure but Magnus
goes for something even uh more wild
Queen to A4 right away and now he says
all right Wesley are you are you game
and Wesley says I am down uh with this I
I have no problem in playing this bishop
captures on F3 uh Knight captures on F3
it's definitely the best move and now
Bishop captures anyone but now Magnus
does not recapture anyone he plays Queen
captures on A7 and now the idea of
course is you get the knights the E5
cover the D7 square and deliver Queen to
A8 Checkmate so can Wesley defend this
yes he can and he does it um uh
beautifully he plays Queen to B4 now how
does this exactly stop the Checkmate
well the idea is that if Magnus goes
Knight to the E5 now the bishop and the
queen are in the same diagonal so now
Queen to A5 stops Checkmate and black is
just better
uh so Magnus goes uh Rook captures on E1
first uh and now Knight captures on G3
you might think but why not G4 it
attacks the the Knight which is
defending the rookani one the problem is
you will kick the queen away from this
diagonal Ponte three and after the queen
moves okay you will trade Queen's laser
captures captures now play 95 it's a
very unclear position okay objectively
uh black is better but it's Armageddon
black already has uh less time on the
clock and just a a very weird position
to have so instead uh Knight captures on
G3 was played by Wesley and now H
captures on G3 and now Queen to B6
offering a queen trade uh here in fact
objectively best was King to D7 but I
mean this is not something you play uh
in pretty much Blitz time control uh how
do you how do you play such a move then
Magnus would of course go after the king
Rook hd8 D captures on C6 and now even
King captures in C6 I don't know if you
can imagine anyone playing this uh very
very hard to say Rook to C1 check King
to D7 and now even Rook to D1 check King
to E6 and after let's say Knight to D4
check you will find a safe haven with
King to F6 and now the black king is
perfectly fine so you did some uh you
know walking around but doesn't matter
it's perfectly fine Wesley went for
Queen to B6 and this does uh give Magnus
some ideas Queen to A8 with checking the
D7 and now Queen to A4
uh Quinta A3 would have been a little
bit uh better as it prevents uh Wesley
from offering some trades with Queen to
B5 but luckily for Magnus Wesley doesn't
play it he plays Pawn to F6 he really
wants to take away this E5 Square from
the Knight and Magnus goes Pawn to B5
interestingly Ponte E5 also works uh in
in the sense that after let's say Rook
hd8 you have to play Queen to C2 go
after Queen to F5 and not after King the
ca2 will still play Queen to F5 checking
to be it and now get this very very
strong pass Pawn let's say Rook capture
Sunny one Knight captures and okay black
is up the exchange but it is white who
will be pushing for the win here instead
Magnus went for Pawn to D5 and now we
have King to C8 Ponte E5 uh the idea
being of course that Magnus really wants
to put his Knight on E5 to control the
D7 Square so King to B8 now you don't
have to worry about Queen T8 and now
just e captures an F6 Magnus creates a
pass Pawn here C captures on D5 and pawn
to F7 and now you have to be in
incredibly precise Rook HD f8 is the
movie you want to play uh Wesley however
played Queen to F6 and now Magnus just
jumps in with knights to E5 and here
Rook H the f8 but now the position is uh
well the position is very weird but
there is one move that sort of ranks
above all others that magnets can play
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this absolutely a great move
for white while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not going for the
uh for the material with knights the D7
with check and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is indeed Rook
to E3 and now look at the scary uh
reality Rook day three is coming and
then Queen to A8 will be Checkmate or
that is what Magnus is hoping for for
those of you who thought about Knight to
D7 check it's it's fine although it will
not yield a full point to Rook captures
on these seven Queen captures and after
Queen captures on F7 you will have to
trade here and then just King to F1 and
okay you could argue that maybe white
has a a bit more of an active King but
still it's a equal material two point
Islands each I mean not not much to look
forward to here with Rook the E3 now the
uh it's uh you know definitely being
played for three results here uh Rook
captures an F7 Wesley has to get rid of
this past Pawn now comes with Rook the
A3 threatening mate in one so Pawn to C6
freeing up the C7 Square for the black
king and now Queen to A7 with check King
to C7 and now Rook the B3 you might even
play Knight captures on F7 first and
then Rock the B3 uh but Magnus decided
against for example Rook to beat and
pawn to A4 and it's very hard that black
will uh get out of this uh instead he
went Rook to B3 right away we have
rooked the B8 the reason why this uh the
previous one could be a little bit
better is because maybe Queen captures
an F2 is an option here like objectively
white is winning but still yeah for
example Rook captures and F2 King
captures an F2 you still uh have some
work to do black does have Five Pawns
your G Pawn is double so yeah you know
in in in Blitz time control you will uh
not have all the time in the world to
figure out a way on how to win this so
this was probably Wesley's best hope but
he wanted to hang on to everything he
played Rook to B8 and now comes Rook to
F3 we can even throw this one in slow
motion there we have it Rook to F3 and
there is no move here for Wesley you
have to capture the Knight night or you
could even play with Queen captures on
F3 probably even better Knight captures
and then try to hold this with two Rooks
but Wesley is not interested in playing
silly positions you know if he lost he
lost he doesn't want to mess around
Queen captures an E5 Rook captures on F7
with check now comes King to d8 as the
queen covers the rook and B8 but now
it's merely a matter of a single check
now Rook the fa check was played and he
was in this position on move 33 that
Wesley so resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here once you
move the king of course The Rook can B8
will be captured and you are now down a
full Rook of course completely
unplayable even after some like Queen T1
checking the H2 there are no checks the
F2 Pawn is covered by the queen so I
mean they don't really care about that
but you are getting checkmated uh fairly
soon you know so it doesn't really
matter after Rook the f8 that Magnus
grabs his first point in the tournament
he did lose the first game in classical
so now even though he got a draw in
classical time format uh he did get a
win against Wesley in Armageddon so at
least you know he he uh he got it going
for himself uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed this first
game that we are showing from round two
I can already see that another very
interesting game has finished while I
was recording this so you know uh
expected that one next uh it was also a
wild one uh so you know stay tuned for
that yeah I would like to thank Marcus
gravel Bunty Revolution reptiles YouTube
Mikhail zakarias and the David gasparian
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful tournament uh
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day